fatal crashes on our roadways they
continue to be a major issue here in
southern nevada we've been talking about
a day in and day out and we're learning
now this year how it's shaping up
compared to 2021 bianca holman joining
us now this morning with that report
bianca how are we doing
hey good morning heather well any life
lost is one too many so this year across
our entire state there have been 46
fatalities and so here's some more
information about the information that
we've learned from our state troopers so
that number is actually down almost 15
percent compared to last year and of
course impairment and speeding major
factors when it comes to these deadly
crashes now of that number 16 where
pedestrians and nine were motorists that
were not wearing their seat belt and
just this weekend we've talked about and
shared this information with you there
was a deadly crash involving two
motorcycles in north las vegas and no
one can forget that horrific crash that
killed a family of seven that happened
at that intersection on cheyenne when
that car ran through the lights and ran
into several vehicles and so coming up
in the next southpaw we're going to
share more information about how clark
county compares to the rest of the
counties here in the state back to you
all in the studio